Trascrizione: Michele Gianella
Revisore: Nicoletta Pedrana
Vi presento Henke.
Henke è un signore di 80 anni
che ha speso la maggior parte
della sua vita a viaggiare,
sia per lavoro che per divertimento.
Henke non ha mai sentito parlare
di sostenibilità,
o di cambiamento climatico.
E Henke non si è mai chiesto
quale fosse lo stato di salute
del nostro pianeta,
e quale il suo futuro.
Vedete, Henke, insieme ad altri,
è una persona importante,
fondamentale, in questa storia.
Prima di tutto, però,
lasciatemi raccontare due cose su di me.
Io sono nato e cresciuto
in un paese della provincia veneta.
Sono un appassionato di montagna,
soprattutto di corse in montagna.
Alcuni anni fa mi sono
laureato in economia,
e da quasi 20 anni ho la fortuna
di lavorare nel mondo dell'outdoor.
E da sei anni vivo ad Amsterdam,
che con le montagne, purtroppo,
non c'azzecca molto.
Io non ho mai dato una grossa importanza
al cambiamento climatico;
e soprattutto, non ho mai pensato
che la cosa riguardasse me
in prima persona,
o che spettasse a me fare qualcosa
per risolvere questo problema.
Questi li conoscete, vero?
I 17 obiettivi di sviluppo sostenibile.
Per me questi sono sempre stati
17 obiettivi astratti,
spiegati in modo estremamente semplice
per permettere a persone comuni, come me,
di capire quali fossero le cose
e gli obiettivi da perseguire
per rendere il nostro pianeta
un posto migliore dove vivere.
Ad ogni modo, gli obiettivi astratti
non hanno mai incentivato né me
né le persone con cui mi relazionavo
a fare qualcosa per raggiungerli,
questi obiettivi.
Infine, io non mi sono mai considerato,
in nessun modo, un attivista.
Poi, un giorno, ho avuto la fortuna
di conoscere questa persona.
Lui si chiama Yvon, Yvon Chouinard;
insieme alla moglie Malinda,
quasi 50 anni fa, hanno creato un'azienda,
un'azienda che esiste tuttora
e si chiama Patagonia.
Che produce, prevalentemente,
abbigliamento per andare in montagna.
Malinda e Yvon, da quasi 50 anni,
hanno una missione:
la loro missione è quella
di utilizzare la loro azienda,
quindi il loro business,
per salvare il nostro pianeta.
Come dicevo, ho avuto
la fortuna di conoscerli,
ho la fortuna tutt'ora
di lavorare per questa azienda.
E grazie a loro, io ho capito delle cose.
E ce ne sono quattro
che vorrei condividere con voi.
La prima è semplicissima:
Questo non è più il momento
di fare finta di niente,
e di voltarci dall'altra parte.
Guardate che persino la scienza
non ci garantirà
che sopravvivremo
a questa crisi climatica.
Pensate che siamo stati noi stessi
a creare un ambiente, nel nostro pianeta,
che non è più sicuro per nessuno di noi.
Ho anche capito che il sistema attuale,
formato dalla classe
politica e industriale,
non è in grado di cambiare
le regole del gioco da solo.
Il sistema cambia solo se è obbligato.
Di conseguenza, è fondamentale
che ci sia una forza che parte dal basso,
e che spinga il sistema a cambiare.
Perché come nel passato,
lo sarà anche nel futuro:
le rivoluzioni partono sempre dal basso.
Ho anche capito che un attivista
non è solamente quella persona
che passa giornate intere a studiare
l'ultimo rapporto scientifico
pubblicato da una rivista specializzata,
o che passa i pomeriggi
a fare volantinaggio.
No, un attivista può essere chiunque,
può essere chiunque di noi abbia voglia
di partecipare ad un'iniziativa
che metta il pianeta al primo posto.
Per esempio, la salvaguardia
degli spazi incontaminati,
la salute e la felicità,
o comunque uno dei 17 obiettivi
di cui vi accennavo prima.
Infine, l'ultima cosa che ho capito
è che questo è il momento di fare.
Dobbiamo immaginare il futuro
in cui vogliamo vivere,
e il futuro che vogliamo
tramandare alle nuove generazioni,
e ogni giorno fare qualcosa di concreto
per far sì che il sogno
si avvicini alla realtà.
Capite che, dopo aver capito queste cose
avevo due possibilità:
o far fare finta di niente,
e girarmi dall'altra parte,
o fare qualcosa di diverso.
Io ho deciso di iniziare
a dire di sì, e fare delle cose.
Mia moglie è vegetariana.
Mia moglie è vegetariana da sempre,
e io l'ho sempre supportata
mantenendo una certa distanza,
continuando a mangiare carne.
Sempre mia moglie mi ha regalato un libro
che parla di come
gli allevamenti intensivi
abbiano impatto sul cambiamento climatico.
Di conseguenza io ho deciso
di fare qualcosa,
ho deciso di diventare vegetariano,
di provare a diventare vegetariano.
Ahimè, non ce l'ho fatta:
non ci sono riuscito.
Però, in questa fase,
ho scoperto delle cose.
Ho scoperto, per esempio,
che uno dei fattori principali
della deforestazione
è dovuta all'incremento, all'espansione
delle coltivazioni di monocolture.
Monocolture che sono, per il 90%,
utilizzate per la produzione di mangimi
per gli allevamenti intensivi.
Ho anche capito, ho anche scoperto
che se noi tutti, individualmente,
riducessimo il consumo giornaliero
di carne e di pesce del 50%,
potremmo contribuire in maniera concreta
al raggiungimento di tre dei 17
Obiettivi di Sviluppo Sostenibile:
Il numero 12, il consumo responsabile;
numero 14, vita sott'acqua;
e obiettivo 15, vita sulla terra.
Capite, io non ce l'ho fatta
a diventare vegetariano,
non sono riuscito a fare questa cosa.
Però io giornalmente, adesso,
contribuisco in maniera concreta
al raggiungimento di questi obiettivi,
e la cosa mi fa comunque
stare abbastanza bene.
Settembre 2019.
Abbiamo deciso di chiudere i nostri uffici
per permettere a tutti noi
di partecipare ad una manifestazione.
Questa manifestazione si chiama
"Fridays for future",
c'è stata anche venerdì.
Quindi io, a 43 anni,
per la prima volta mi sono trovato
per strada a manifestare.
Io ero convintissimo
di trovarmi circondato
da ragazzi scappati di casa,
ragazzi che avevano trovato
una buona scusa
per non andare a scuola,
o per saltare una lezione all'università.
E invece mi sbagliavo.
Ero circondato da persone di tutte le età:
genitori con i propri figli;
nonni con i propri nipoti;
persone di qualsiasi
estrazione sociale e colore.
Di qualsiasi orientamento
sessuale, e credo.
E proprio quel giorno,
ho capito una cosa fondamentale per me.
Ho capito che il movimento
per la protezione del clima
non ha come singolo e unico obiettivo
la protezione del nostro pianeta.
Ma anche delle persone
che ci vivono, nel nostro pianeta.
Dobbiamo capire quali sono gli squilibri,
e le disuguaglianze strutturali,
e risolverli.
Perché guardate che non ci può essere
giustizia climatica,
senza una giustizia sociale.
Una giustizia sociale
che tuteli tutti, a prescindere.
Ottobre, ottobre 2019.
Presi dall'entusiasmo
con alcuni amici e colleghi
in questo caso abbiamo deciso
di partecipare a una protesta,
una protesta organizzata da un gruppo
che si chiama Extinction Rebellion.
Eravamo tra gli "arrestabili":
in questo caso, l'azienda per cui lavoro
ci ha fornito un corso
di resistenza non violenta;
e ci ha messo a disposizione un avvocato,
appunto in caso di arresto.
Ad ogni modo, alle cinque di mattina
di un giorno di ottobre
500 persone hanno bloccato
una delle arterie principali di Amsterdam
e ci siamo seduti alle cinque
di mattina per 16 ore.
E devo dire che a 43 anni,
seduti sull'asfalto,
a ottobre, con l'umidità
e alzarmi solo per andare in bagno,
non è stato sempre divertente,
ma qualche sorriso c'è stato.
Alcuni di noi sono stati arrestati,
portati nella caserma locale
e rilasciati alcune ore dopo.
Altri, me compreso,
sono stati caricati in alcuni autobus
e ci hanno portato
due ore fuori da Amsterdam,
in aperta campagna olandese.
Lì ci hanno scaricato, e ci hanno detto
"Adesso sono fatti vostri tornare a casa".
Comunque, sapete chi ho incontrato?
Ho incontrato ragazzi
e ragazze di ogni età
che protestavano per il nostro pianeta.
Non per il loro: il nostro pianeta.
Ho incontrato Sara,
la ragazza col berretto arancione,
che è una designer di 25 anni.
Lei crede fortemente
che se siamo in questa situazione
la colpa è nostra,
della nostra generazione.
E che spetta a lei,
e alla sua, di generazione,
sistemare le cose.
Ho anche incontrato Christel,
la signora qui.
È una signora francese,
è madre di due figlie
e vedova di un marito
che all'inizio degli anni '80
è riuscito a scappare da Berlino Est
scavalcando il muro,
appunto per andare da Christel,
Christel è un’inguaribile ottimista.
Lei, nonostante tutto,
crede ancora nel prossimo,
e crede che insieme riusciremo
a vincere questa battaglia.
Infine, sapete chi ho incontrato?
Io lì ho incontrato Henke
per la prima volta.
Henke, questo signore di 80 anni,
quando ha saputo
che c'era questa protesta,
lui si è alzato dal suo divano,
ha preso la bicicletta,
si è fatto dieci chilometri,
è venuto lì tra gli arrestabili,
e si è fatto arrestare!
E si è fatto arrestare
per un semplice motivo:
perché lui vuole garantire
un posto dove vivere, il nostro pianeta,
ai suoi quattro nipoti.
Cosa ho imparato da queste esperienze?
Prima di tutto, ho imparato
un'altra cosa abbastanza semplice.
Quello che mi dicevano i miei nonni,
i miei genitori, quando avevo 20 anni,
non era vero.
"Eh noi, alla tua età...".
No, i ragazzi di oggi
sono decisamente meglio
della mia generazione.
Guardate che di Greta Thunberg
è pieno il mondo, l'Italia, Mantova.
Basta sapere dove cercarle.
E quando le troviamo,
la nostra responsabilità
è quella di ascoltarle
e incoraggiarle per combattere
in ciò in cui credono.
Ho anche imparato che abbiamo
un'opportunità enorme, di fronte a noi:
quella di combattere questa battaglia
per la protezione del nostro pianeta,
l'unico che abbiamo,
insieme ai nostri figli
e ai nostri nipoti.
E abbiamo anche l'opportunità
di dimostrare loro
che noi non vogliamo,
e non siamo parte del problema
ma che vogliamo essere
parte della soluzione.
Infine, ho imparato
che se vogliamo fare questo
dobbiamo cambiare linguaggio.
Dobbiamo guardare al mondo
con più ottimismo,
anche se c'è incertezza.
Dobbiamo essere più positivi,
e dobbiamo sorridere.
Perché, come ci insegna Henke,
le rivoluzioni si fanno
anche con il sorriso.
Infine, vi voglio lasciare con questo.
Per fare qualcosa di buono,
innanzitutto dobbiamo fare qualcosa.
Questo per il momento
è il mio, di qualcosa.
Io oggi vi invito e vi auguro
di trovare il vostro.
Perché sapete, quando
ci guarderemo indietro,
vorremmo riconoscerci
tra i tanti spettatori
di questa crisi climatica,
o tra quelli che hanno fatto
qualcosa per risolverla?
(Applausi)